bonjour à tous on m'a demandé
d'intervenir ici dont le de trouver un
thème donc ça va un petit peu le thème
de la première interlocutrice qui est
venu c'est qu'allez vous faire de vos 25
jours donc moi je me présente je
m'appelle rich
je suis un homme français j'ai je suis
nourrie des années 70 j'ai une heure une
campagne assez reculée donc je vais
m'orienter pas du tout à faire ce genre
de choses et finalement mes parents ont
décidé de poser
pas très loin de la région parisienne et
pour moi d'arriver en ville c'était une
révélation je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte mais pas celle de la
campagne à la ville
c'était quelque chose d'exceptionnel
c'était l'arrivée de vie peuvent arriver
de la radio libre l'arrivée du snarr des
graffitis et pour moi ça a vraiment été
l'impression de vivre à cent pour cent
pour vous dire mon premier graffiti
c'était dans les toilettes quand j'avais
six ans j'ai écrit les noms de mon
amoureuse avec un message à vendre à
côté d'elle il était le début des ennuis
soumah veulent une bonne punition mais
c'était aussi une des raisons pour moi
c'était d'un coup j'ai senti que pour
moi c'était presque indispensable alors
jusqu'au vérité qui était ni bonne ni
mauvaise ni plutôt un endroit dans
lequel je me sentais pas spécialement
l'aise j'ai tout de suite su que
j'allais l'art et la peinture sur une
flamme pour moi après j'ai décidé de
m'orienter vers un cursus semi
artistique en étudiant l'histoire de la
entraînant un petit peu aux beaux-arts
et j'ai peaufiné tout ça avec la
communication
donc vous pouvez voir mon travail mon
travail tourne principalement autour des
marges alors c'est pas un travail de
dénonciation de la marque
c'est simplement un travail de création
d'échelle
on va créer une échelle dans laquelle la
personne qui regarde le graffiti va
pendant que se positionner
ah ah
et donc pour faire ces graffitis là vous
imaginez bien que ça prend un petit peu
de temps donc j'ai une double vie
je suis marié j'ai deux enfants donc
j'ai une première ville matin qui
commence à 7h qui finit à 20h 20h30 et
j'ai une deuxième vie qui commence à 21h
et qui finit jusqu'à très tard le soir
et alors pourquoi je fais ça c'est la
question que l'on peut se poser
je suis un enfant de la télévision je
suis pas un enfant d'internet j'ai pas
grandi avec un portable dans la main
mais plutôt avec un stylo d'analysé
souvent si tu veux le savoir quoi faire
en mithois et qui saura quoi faire une
fois que cet ennui ce que vont forcément
forcément vous orienter vers les fonds
qui vous intéresse et pour lesquels vous
sentez que vous êtes fait c'est un peu
le discours de caroline moi j'ai connu
divers choses comme la chute du mur de
berlin
j'ai connu le monde qu'on n'y avait pas
internet mais j'ai vu aussi leurs crocs
le la façon dont le monde se remobilise
et sur lui-même avec la montée tous les
extrémistes aux quatre coins du monde
le cours sur la consommation et la
destruction de l'environnement
tout cela avec une couverture médiatique
extrêmement importante donc on va
imposer des images auxquelles je n'avais
pas le choix de prendre 20 sur lesquels
je n'ai pas le choix d'être que
téléspectateurs et un jour j'ai eu
vraiment une overdose d'image avec un à
la vue d'un petit
no comment je sais pas si vous
connaissez c'est sur euronews
et là il y avait trente secondes de
prise de vue où il montrait un enfant
qui est en train de chercher des fourmis
dans le désert pour les manger s'il est
varié et à la fin de ce programme
on a vu la pub qu'ils disent est ce
qu'on vous a été présenté par la maison
et de l'est avec des mannequins qui
monte dans le super jet privé donc il
est vraiment un décalage entre les deux
et là j'ai compris tout de suite qu'ils
avaient quelque chose à faire enfin j'ai
trouvé cette pouvait être éventuellement
ma voix vous avez créé une série qui
s'appelle art expo article qui reprend
démarque donc des marques de luxe pour
aller d'un côté de trop de richesses et
qui associés avec un une image d'enfant
pauvre ça c'est un sas était un graffiti
pour montrer la façon le monde y du fait
que l'europe atelier d'état devrait
juger mais en réalité n'en voulait pas
donc j'ai un peu comparé des réfugiés
des ordures en fait pour que ce soit une
image un peu forte
ça c'est encore un autre un autre de la
série art qu est ce qu a sorti donc je
rappelle que cherche tout ça par exemple
c'est complètement illégal
c'est pour ça que j'ai ce masque
aujourd'hui on risque plus de 50000
euros damende d'écrire sur l'union donc
je vous le conseille pas mais quand on
veut diffuser un message qui me tient
enfin quand je décide de diffuser ce
message qui ne tient vraiment à coeur
mon but c'est de ces d'être vu si on
veut avoir un message fort et porteur le
mieux c'est donc dans la rue
donc ça vaut le coup de prendre un
risque parlons si vous êtes un graffiti
à la gare du nord tous les jours à
l'égard du nord il ya sept cent mille
personnes qui passent pour positionner
bien vous allez doit être touchées même
que 1 % et 1 % de 708 personnes c'est
quand même sept mille personnes
donc ça permet d'avoir un discours
visible sans équivoque ce que je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de on peut pas se
tromper ça c'est un magasin de l'ue
lit-on dans paris ça c'était un graffiti
sur le problème de la du nucléaire dans
le monde et de la pollution que ça
engendre
ça a été sélectionné pour le prix du
graffiti 2015 c'est organisé par edf en
plus donc ils ont quand même un petit
peu d'humour
mais l'on prié ils ont pas si ils sont
pas si fermé que ça à l'humour ça
c'était un graffiti sur j'avais une
émission à jour qui mettait en scène des
façons dont les milices croquer les
bains accueille des enfants et les rocs
et les recrutent pour devenir enfants
soldats
vous savez comment ils font ils ont une
technique très simple il arrive dans les
villages en afrique où les gens n'ont
pas grand chose avec des pick-up chargés
de produits de consommation que les gens
ne peuvent pas s'offrir genre des nike
et il offre sa aux enfants et les
enfants du coup se rapproche de et un
certain nombre reste reste dans la
milice ça c'était pareil brillé à chaque
fois je prends mes marques paris
détournées de leur sens originel
ça c'était l'avant charlie hebdo c'était
bien de moi avant et c'était à l'époque
où les les comment dire les jambes des
shs partait aussi enfin été sur la syrie
est assez absolument tous les monuments
historiques n'était pas musulman et sous
l'oeil de la communauté internationale
qui ne faisait absolument rien donc il a
fallu attendre qu'il des attentats en
europe pour qu'on se penche sur ce
problème et ce graffiti est resté moins
d'une journée
il était tout de suite enlevé ou
décrocher ou arrachées je ne sais quoi
dans quelle technique pour 8 pour faire
des trucs aussi rapide nous avez pu le
voir c'est le cauchemar
le pochoir c'est très simple on ma
technique c'est d'être j'ai une idée en
tête
j'ai ma phrase pas ma phrase et je
prends la photo en grand j'essaye de
projeter monde est comme si c'était la
lumière donc je vais projeté mon oeil
sur la photo j'ai dégagé des zones
blanches et des hommes noirs donc des
autres claire et des zones d'ombré et
ensuite ça donne ça enfin il ya
plusieurs il ya plusieurs tests avant
d'arriver à ça mais la technique du
pochoir et parfaite parce qu'elle vit
que j'agis dans la rue je suis obligée
de le faire très vite ce qui est de la
police qui passe souvent ou des gens ou
donc si je veux faire quelque chose de
propre et avec du sens suggère de passer
par le pro choix
ça c'était une c'était à l'époque où mon
mari était bloqué par la construction
d'un parking souterrain et que c'était
un petit peu fatigant et donc j'ai
décidé de mettre ce graffiti fa très
loin des travaux il n'est pas resté très
longtemps non plus mais il est pas mal
de succès j'ai eu pas mal de relais
dessus et il s'est trouvé que l'effet
sur la maison de quelqu'un qui travaille
dans une grande école de commerce et
sanaa times a contactés pour faire après
une conférence à cette école de commerce
ça c'était après les attentats de
charlie hebdo juste après donc ça a été
fait investi dans la république il est
resté va vraiment pas mal de temps
j'aime bien les phrases aussi je pense
que des phrases c'est relativement choc
une phrase assez courtes s'est affichée
dans la rue et les gens passent devant
et ça mon but c'est quand même de cette
porter un message est de faire réfléchir
et en fait quand on regarde bien mon
travail je pense que c'est l'addition de
tous g c'est quelque chose qui se fait
naturellement c'est quelque chose que
j'aime ça recueillent tous et toutes les
choses que j'aime j'ai eu une première
révélation par rapport à l'heure quand
j'étais au collège j'ai été visité le
musée du prado et fait tomber sur lyrica
et la mise en scène de guernica c'est
quand même exceptionnel dans ce musée là
et c'est une première révélation
deuxième révélation c'était de voir des
tableaux de jackson pollock sais pas si
vous connaissez c'est un artiste
abstrait américain et cdc des tableaux
qui sont comme des cris et large le
conçois comme ça je le conçois vraiment
comme un incident du quai rhin qui du
fond du fond de notre propre intérieur
après j'ai des messages aussi qu'ils ne
prennent pas en compte de marques un
message plus plus classique est
peut-être un peu moins fort et moins
porté sur le social mais ce sont des
choses qui me tiennent à coeur parce que
j'avais ma petite fille là c'est mon
petit garçon la sas assure simon laisse
des messages
quand il part à bruxelles en vacances il
écrit des choses sur les murs dit que
son père ait un vendeur avec ça lui
plaît pas trop apparemment donc c'est
marrant aussi c'est qu'elle a
originalement c'était l'anarchie dans le
dans la bulle est quelqu'un qui a passé
de la mairie de paris europe 1 le a est
quelqu'un reconnaît quelque chose de
super alors ça c'était comme tout le
monde je pense que tout le monde est un
peu choqué par charlie hebdo même si
c'est un attentat parmi tant d'autres
dans ce qui se passe dans ce monde mais
j'ai eu besoin de faire une pierre
tombale dell pourrait lui poser devant
donc c'est une pierre tombale qui
restait un peu plus d'une semaine qu'ils
ont dit quand même un petit peu galéré
pour le risque que je l'avais coller le
camp scellement industriels
à mon avis ce genre marteau piqueur au
même mais il est parti des partis quand
même donc tout cela pour vous dire que
mamie on écoles amené à faire des choses
là c'est illégal ce que je fais
clairement j'ai pas le droit de faire ça
mais c'est quelque chose qui vient
vraiment du fond quand vous sentez qu'il
ya quelque chose qui vient du fond de
votre coeur ou deux c'est un besoin mais
faites-le fait le sait sinon vous aurez
un regret après et c'est bien le savoir
en sait quelque chose
moi je suis partie sur du graffiti ça
m'a permis de rencontrer plein de gens
des gens tout aussi différents les uns
des autres dans la vie c'est ce qu'elle
veut c'est des rencontres donc déjà un
jour j'ai fait un graffiti dans le
marais je pensais pas faire un graffiti
est en droit et en fait il s'est trouvé
que c'était la porte d'un très grand
réalisateur de français et qui m'a
contacté ensuite pour qu'ils créent un
tableau ce qu'il a accumulé beaucoup de
tableaux donc ça m'a permis de ça me
permet de rencontrer des gens aussi
différents les uns des autres
j'ai été aussi contacté par des des
actifs à un acteur hollywoodien j'ai eu
enfin des fils de gens très très célèbre
qui jouent au foot au psg
enfin c'était je recompte des gens si
j'étais resté moi même au départ enfin
j'aurais jamais rencontré autant de
personnes
j'aurais jamais tant réussi de toutes
ces rencontres donc n'hésitez vraiment
pas faire les choses faites ce que vous
avez à faire parce que vous n'avez que
25000 jours à vivre